any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to another sure to be
thrilling and fascinating episode of the
into the impossible podcast because it
features
my friend
my
inspiration and muse in some of my
writing and that's paul halpert is a
professor at the university of the
sciences in philadelphia the author of
many many books recipient of a
guggenheim fellowship and the fellow of
the american physical society
he lives near the cradle of our
democracy in philadelphia uh paul how
are you doing today
i'm doing great thanks so much for
having me back on your show brian this
book is so uh so fascinating i thought i
knew most of the stories in it i thought
i understood the stakes which could not
be bigger it's really the creation of
all that is the matter that matters
the matter that matters the protons the
neutrons the croutons uh that are so
important to me and uh a lot of it takes
place here in la jolla in san diego
where ucsd is located so it's delightful
and thank you so much for giving me an
acknowledgment in the book i don't
deserve it but uh i will take anything i
can get from you because you are one of
my inspirations when i write paul thank
you so much for coming on this book
we'll definitely get into all the
details of it although i never like to
give it away it's out today when this
video comes out it's sure to be a
bestseller and uh for for all the right
reasons this book characterizes the
struggle to understand the universe uh
in its first and earliest moments and to
understand the contradiction between an
eternal universe or a steadily evolving
universe in a static steady state
perhaps from all eternity till now
and really it humanizes the characters
that made this so uh so important so the
first thing i always love to ask paul as
you know from being on the show before
is the title and the cover we call this
judging books by their covers you're
never supposed to do it um i know now i
have a prior for you because of all your
great books but uh for my audience why
is this book have the title that it does
in the subtitle and the cover design
well
it's interesting um i'm especially proud
of the title of this one i came up with
that and flashes of creation has a
double meaning so one meaning is the
idea of how was the universe created and
how did the matter come about in the
universe how were the chemical elements
created
and the two people i talked about in the
book george gamav and fred hoyle had
different ideas for how the chemical
elements were created and surprisingly
it was a combination of both of their
ideas that turns out to be the real
story
george gamma brilliantly
discovered how the
hydrogen and helium in the universe was
created particularly how the helium was
built up during the big bang and fred
hoyle
looked at the higher elements beyond
that and discovered how all the other
elements were created in the cores of
dying stars and released during
supernova explosions which is remarkable
and these were insights by these two men
they were mavericks they were people who
went by their gut feelings and that's
the other meaning of the title flashes
of creation they would get a flash of an
idea and go with it and gamov got so
many ideas when he was at george
washington university he would call
edward teller his colleague every single
day in the morning and come up with
another crazy idea and taylor would
often dismiss the ideas but every once
in a while he stumbled upon something he
went with it and then within a day or
two he'd come up with some new theory
for example his model of alpha decay he
developed overnight
and it's still used today
which also can be used uh
in the reverse manner to see how
uh protons and alpha particles and and
other
particles can be used in colliders uh to
be aimed at targets and he developed
those calculations like very very
quickly so these flashes of creation of
both figures in the book were very very
important and drove them toward uh
amazing creativity but as i show in the
book sometimes they'd be way off and
hoyle was especially very stubborn with
his ideas and kept going with them even
beyond when they were
feasible at all
like beyond when the cosmic microwave
background was discovered he kept coming
up with new ideas for why it wasn't the
big bang it was something else which uh
alienated him from people the cover was
designed by the wonderful people at
basic books hachette
and that is kind of a rendition an
artist rendition of the big bang
which nobody can really imagine
yeah we'll talk about that as i've been
focusing on
some solo episodes lately on competitive
models that still exist through the
singular big bang the the uh origin
story that gamma really supported and
and uh really doesn't get the the
attention that i think he deserves uh
although he was extremely uh well known
at least by scientist standards for his
popularization mr tompkins series 123
infiniti these are wonderful books that
really set the stage for people like you
and me to write popular science books
and accounts and so forth although he's
such a he's such a master of it um you
mentioned already the cmb i was um not
planning to go there but i do so soon of
course i'm going to go there it's mine
it pays the bills around here
but um
i didn't know this that in uh that la
jolla might be
the origin place for where the cmb took
uh first first was predicted perhaps so
you say
uh you say the most notable face-to-face
encounter between gamov and hoyle took
place in the summer of 1956 when gamav
was working as a consultant for the
defense company general dynamics here in
la jolla california he invited hoyle for
a visit
while driving along the seaside enclave
sunny streets and gamov's cadillac which
is kind of funny
they had an animated discussion about
the temperature of space their discourse
anticipated in some ways penzias and
wilson's discovery of the cmb radiation
uh and i just thought that was so
delightful that we have this connection
here in my
my adopted hometown of la jolla
california to this amazing you know
prediction but um i guess before we get
into the nuts and bolts of that
prediction set the stage for these two
men uh they were similar and they were
very different they were um family men
but they were also subject to their own
biases that eventually had not
catastrophic but but negative
implications on their children that they
loved and in some cases in both cases
collaborated with right i mean both men
collaborated with their own children i
think it's wonderful but they also had
uh you know as they say
great men great women how can have great
flaws too talk about them as human
beings
well they both were interested in
conveying science to the general public
they grew up with a great love of
science a great love of nature a love
for astronomy they both looked up at the
skies gammov looked up at the skies over
odessa and observed haley's comet when
he was a child
and hoyle went out into the countryside
and had this moment of epiphany when he
looked up at the stars and decided he
wanted to be an astronomer although that
took him took many twists and turns
he originally was going to pursue
chemistry and went to physics and then
finally uh
this discovered that he was interested
in supernovas uh when he met up with
walter body
and uh was interested in that story and
turned to astrophysics uh both of them
actually turned to astrophysics
relatively late in life career-wise
because they were both more interested
in in nuclear physics
and other fields in the beginning but
then found that astrophysics and
cosmology were great areas of
application for those fields but in
terms of their children i had the
privilege of interviewing all three of
their children which was very exciting
uh unfortunately igor gamoff passed away
recently a couple of months ago but he
was an incredible person and very very
animated and he was very proud of
talking about his dad
and so were uh liz butler
who was hoyle's uh daughter
and uh jeff hoyle jeff hoyle
collaborated with his father on science
fiction novels
eager gamov continued the mr tompkins
series
almost until his final year
through comic books so they were very
proud of continuing their their parents
legacy
and uh another interesting thing about
their children is that
both igor and liz butler were rebels
they
uh
turned away from science for a while and
then they went back to science and that
shows the power of their father's
influence uh so in terms of the
personalities
both of them were very self-driven they
both had a love of hollywood i
discovered they liked different kinds of
movies hoyle loved mystery movies and as
i show in my book
there was a mystery movie a horror movie
the dead of night that inspired helped
inspire the steady state theory gamma of
on the other hand surprisingly loved
cowboy movies and his nickname was joe
cowboy joe
spelled g-e-o
so if you hear someone talking about
gamavuno nougamov they talk about joe
and say wait a minute joe g-o-e no g-e-o
which was short for
the russian for
george galmoff so um and he adopted that
nickname when he was working with niels
bohr
in copenhagen and there's a funny story
about that because he
and
uh borg challenged each other to a duel
because they had an argument over why
heroes
win
battles in in cowboy movies when the
villain has the advantage because the
villain is evil the villain
comes up and will do a sneak attack but
they demonstrated this
using
toy pistols
and it turned out that boer who argued
for the hero uh ended up being first
and uh but anyway uh
gamov continued to love cowboy movies
and that's when he adopted the name joe
and his son uh became kind of a cowboy
has had a ranch
uh out in uh near boulder colorado
yeah where they re where he relocated
after uh many years at
george washington and um
i think you know when i read the book by
the way your
equal in your storytelling ability
equals only your research ability this
book is so thoroughly researched and
again i'm sitting in the office not this
moment but my office as i told you
before in our last interview is jeffrey
burbridge's old office so i i'm privy to
all of his uh old notes and and so i
mean his his daughter sarah as you know
and you quote in the book um they took
his notes and the library here has
margaret says but every now and then
i'll find you know scrap of paper with
uh with his handwriting on it or or a
photographic plate of a quasar that
margaret took you know before uh you or
i were probably even born and you just
dig into the history so thoroughly
with historians you know ability uh
scholars insights but also as you know
telling this story as a storyteller in a
way that physicists like me can really
appreciate and learn something so i
don't want you to respond to that but i
just want to be uh equally or or
appropriately effusive because it's so
much fun i don't have that much time to
read books about stuff i already know
right i read this book i learned so much
and it's just such a treat i want to go
through one one theme that stuck out to
me and maybe it wasn't intentional but
the um the interplay with bob dickey at
uh at princeton
my late great grand advisor
david wilkinson at princeton and and
other characters and kind of the twin uh
aspects of the 20th century in which
these two the milieu in which they were
operating and it was kind of after world
war ii and at both the kind of nuclear
and the atomic age shines through in
their work obviously in the uh fusion
processes that take place in both oils
and in uh and in gammob's work but also
uh the influence of radar and radio
astronomy and telecommunications and
communications in general
that was always known to me and david
kaiser our mutual friend at mit has
pointed this out um along with uh their
mutual fascination in the origin of life
in in other words in how life could have
come about and that was sort of related
to you know roswell and all the stuff
that would go on in the 40s and 50s
and that was another aspect of the
atomic age the post-world war ii milieu
in which they grew up so were these men
you know uh except for their scientific
claims were they ideological brothers in
arms i mean would they have in an other
world another universe in the multiverse
where they have basically been you know
two sides of the same coin
well um
i'm not not doug adams but i tried to
delve into my book about life the
universe and everything yeah i love that
i love that expression
and interestingly
both gamma v and hoyle were fascinated
by
those topics they wanted to unravel not
just the origin of everything
not just the origin of all matter but
also the origin of life and uh
gamov was more successful than hoyle
because gamov
contacted experts he contacted james
watson
and uh and and spoke with him about you
know the genetic code and came up with
this idea of using combinatorics to
understand how amino acids are created
from genetic material which was a
brilliant idea and was incorporated by
the geneticists
so they still give a tribute to gamma
for that
and hoyle
was
somebody who
turned to
turn to the idea of life later on but it
wasn't so successful because
he was um
not so much reliant on experts
and uh he came up with a little bit of a
strange theory
uh that all diseases came from space or
come from space
which um
people some people were offended by that
and put off by that understandably when
he talked about you know for example
uh aids coming from space
and legionnaires to see is coming from
space people were like what's going on
here he seems you know way off uh
something's wrong and that was his l in
his later years right now
uh he did enough brilliant stuff in his
earlier years then we can um you know
dismiss his later years
yeah he was seemed to be always guided
by his intuition whereas you know you
seem to
portray gamma is much more methodical in
a way although he seems more mercurial
more mischievous uh etc famously adding
people to uh to to to papers to as to
make a pun i mean you can't even imagine
such things happening today uh
beta is not a bad co-author to add if
you have to add somebody
but the thing about hoyle i i felt like
the more he got uh entrenched in in his
beliefs the more he became a scientific
community outsider and that maybe made
him kind of suffer from maybe
confirmation bias or some form of
paranoia that everything's out to you
know kind of oppose him and even i
talked to giant narlikar earlier this
year who you point out is a titanic
figure still to this day in india and
his wife mangala is is just equal and
in every way to him and i just had such
a delightful time talking to them i miss
when they would visit here i hope they
will again
but giant still maintains the steady
state quasi-steady state is is viable
the big bang has serious problems and i
wanted to point out and you mentioned
this in the book the classic story is
that the cmb killed the steady state but
you point out in the book in 1972
weinberg's you know gravitational
cosmology he basically talks about the
steady state as having all these virtues
because it's falsifiable it's not like
genesis 1-1
all the reasons that hoyle didn't like
the big bang are additional reasons that
hoyle didn't like the big bang
hoyle certainly wasn't malevolent but uh
but i don't believe that that the
general you know community of
cosmologists is correct in assuming the
cmb killed the the steady state in fact
as you noted and i i know in my book
the dickey people's roles in wilkinson
paper never mentions the big bang not at
all it only mentions the collapse of a
previous cycle
and and of course who is more
knowledgeable about this than peebles
and and dickie obviously so anyway uh
what do you make of this notion in the
popular culture is it just a shortcut is
it a crutch that we use to just have a
nice just so story as rudyard kipling
called it that the cmb killed the steady
state
yeah it's it's very simplistic to say
you know big bang one fred hoyle lost
end of story uh because he pointed out
correctly that there were
some conceptual problems with the big
bang
especially
uh
the big bang theory as known in the
1960s uh they had to
resolve the issue of the hubble constant
pip
pin that down uh pinned down a number of
the cosmological parameters
uh originally when and then in 1948
when um gamma was advocating the big
bang theory along with uh alfred herman
uh the age of the universe was estimated
to be a couple of billion years old
which is much younger than
than the stars so that was a big problem
i would say that's like finding out your
your father is younger than you it's a
little disconcerting
so until that that problem was fixed
um steady state seemed much more viable
and then there were all these problems
with the flatness problem isotropy
problem and so forth that we're resolved
as as most
uh cosmologists think by inflation of of
course there's alternative ideas cyclic
cosmologies and so forth yeah we'll get
to when when inflation came about as i
show in my book
hoyle
sort of claimed a triumph he said look
the inflation people are talking about
this
exponential expansion phase well that's
what i was talking about
instead of talking about
an influential field some field driving
inflation just for a fraction of a
second why not just have a creation
field which was hoyle's idea yeah slowly
creating matter
over the eons continuously then you
don't have what's called an inflation
the graceful exit problem why did
inflation stop
hoyle was saying well inflation didn't
stop it was really steady state or
quasi-steady-state that new matter and
energy is very very slowly being uh
introduced into the universe and the
universe is expanding and it existed
forever
so um some people think hoyle should
have adopted some form of the
inflationary universe and and said
you know okay
inflationary universe is similar enough
to steady-state you know i'll just go
within eternal inflation
but uh hoyle still didn't like the idea
that even even the idea that the
observable universe has a beginning
because he thought that that was not
testable
so he wasn't willing to say okay maybe
the observable universe has a beginning
as a bubble in some kind of greater
universe which would have been a logical
leap for him but he wasn't willing to
take that leap
um yeah and
it was it was it was maybe because it
was so antithetical although i i as you
point out in the book and and many of
the listeners who already know you know
hoyle had uh come up with the idea that
in some sense provided at least one of
the nails in the coffin of the
quasi-steady state theory which is that
helium production in stars was
insufficient to generate the observed
24.5
helium abundance in our universe and he
knew that and he wrote you know this
wonderful paper taylor that you that you
uh call out uh and so he wasn't afraid
of torpedoing his own ideas uh and he
wasn't afraid to go out on a limb as you
point out in the famous hoyle miracle
the resonant uh 13 mev resonance of of
carbon of beryllium that allows for us
to exist i mean that was as his daughter
as you got her her quote you know he she
basically like he's he predicted it on
the basis of his own existence so it's
kind of like an update to you know
kogito or gosum i'm carbon therefore i
exist uh talk about how a great you know
intellect like him was so
scientifically in uh had such scientific
integrity that he could dismiss an idea
or he could promulgate another idea
which could be fatal to a previous idea
and yet be so stubborn so resolute that
they would continue to put out books and
books and papers and so forth about an
idea which by the i would say by the you
know fire ass experiment and by wmap it
had become impossible to believe in the
whisker theory of thermalization of
starlight so
what did you take away from him i mean
is he just so complicated that you know
he's bound to have some nutty kind of
ideas or to hold on to ideas far too
long or suffer from confirmation bias or
do you think there's a grain of truth
like you were just hinting at i mean
there are uh kind of i wouldn't say you
know real uh uh dna maybe there's some
rna
of inflation and even dark energy right
let's be honest i mean that's just like
some kind of you know creation field of
energy right uh so there are some
elements of that in there but still he
wouldn't fully adopt them what do you
make of that with hoyle is very
different than gammov i would say well
very interesting hoyo's last paper
uh i think published in uh right before
he died 2001 was was actually a joint
paper but uh tried to explain dark
energy
so he he kept up with stuff although by
that time he was impaired
sadly in his final years he had a tragic
tragic accident
where he was hiking uh near his the
house where he grew up in
and uh somehow slipped down a ravine
and
her injured himself very badly he was uh
he was unconscious for a long time
before he was rescued and that that
interfered with his cognitive ability in
his last couple of years but
um he still
you know had a joint authored paper at
that time and his book was released
around that time
um one thing that i i found out from his
daughter
uh was a fact that was a factor in his
later years so you see a sharp break
between hoyle
in up to the 1970s and then hoyle in the
1970s and later because even in the
1960s
hoyle was willing to
admit that
the big bang could be right i mean he
sort of briefly
was pro big bang you know well we have
no other explanation for the helium
abundance you know
we need something to explain where all
the helium comes from so maybe the big
bang and he said maybe little banks
uh
but the problem was
in the early 1970s
the institute that he founded in
cambridge
was closed that was converted into
something else and he was very upset
about it
and he left cambridge early
before he was
eligible to retire
and went off to a mountaintop
in a very remote part of england the
lake district of england
now his daughter said that at that point
he had a lot of connections in the
united states he had connections at
caltech his connections at rice
university
so he could have gone easily gone to
caltech or to rice university and then
of course at uh san diego there was
bourbon the burbages he could have gone
to probably going to san diego so he
would have been
very much more productive
and much more integrated into the
mainstream astrophysics community if he
had moved to the united states but his
wife barbara
put her foot down and wanted to stay in
england
and he loved nature he loved
the wilderness
he would have loved and did love the
times he spent in southern california
that would have been great or he could
have you know
spend time other places in the united
states uh like gamma off he loved
frontier areas he loved wild areas
but he wasn't
allowed because of his his wife's
preferences
to to resettle so they went to lake
district and there really almost no one
could visit them they could visit maybe
in the summer
come all the way up there visit for a
couple of days but there wasn't this
regular commerce
and some of us remember
the days before
email and the internet
you would have to go to a university
library to look for
paper journals
and then you would have to mail your
articles to people
so if you were in a remote area where
there wasn't access to a university
library you would have to rely on your
own journal subscriptions which took
weeks to get to you so you you would you
would not be able to keep up with
everything and that's the problem hoyle
couldn't keep up with the astrophysics
community so he started just going with
his gut feelings
and he was writing a lot of books and
started to think about
you know odd ideas like the idea of
germs from space the idea that a fossil
in a london natural history museum was
faked
was forged which he had real no real
evidence for
but he began to be grouped in with
create creationists which was supremely
ironic
because
he was not religious at all and didn't
really believe in the beginning of the
universe but creationists started to
love him because he was questioning
darwin's idea of evolution on earth and
looking to the space so some
creationists were like you see this top
scientist is saying darwin is wrong
and
yeah and then there was plenty of
scientists who would be happy to throw
him under the bus and including put him
in in league with uh with creation young
earth creationist i will say that i did
recently
provide a blurb for a book by steven c
meyer who is a cambridge phd in
philosophy of science and he wrote a
book called return of the god hypothesis
in which he asserts that you know hoyle
kind of came to and he's a
i would say he's an intelligent design
advocate
and not a young earth creationist by any
means but uh but nevertheless uh he
claimed that hoyle
in large part due to not the
archaeopteryx that you mentioned and not
the germs from space but really the
fine-tuning the hoyle miracle the
beryllium resonance that that was kind
of indicative to him that the universe
was tuned uh and the quote is something
like by a designer did you come across
any of that kind of in your scholarship
along the way paul
one has to be careful and i'm always
careful when researching
what people say in their later years
compared to what they say in their
earlier years
and uh a lot of physicists
including people like heisenberg
einstein and so forth in their later
years to become more philosophical and
they say oh well philosophy drove me to
these conclusions
and i think hoyle
came up with the
residence idea the beryllium resident's
idea for carbon 12
and
it was a hunch
and
there there isn't anything written by
him at that time which makes use of the
anthropic principle but then in the
1980s
the anthropic principle became
extremely popular there were books out
on the anthropic principle and a lot of
people started making anthropic
arguments and just for viewers out there
who don't know what the anthropic
principle is the idea
that the conditions in the universe were
fine-tuned in such a way
that
we are here that intelligent conscious
life is here and if they were slightly
different then you wouldn't have
conscious entities and that's when oil
said okay well if it weren't for this
carbon beryllium carbon resonance
uh then carbon wouldn't be created there
wouldn't be any life in the universe and
we wouldn't be here to talk about it so
he made that argument
more later in life and he said that wow
i was the first one he said to use
anthropic reasoning
and maybe we don't know what went on
inside his head so maybe that was
in some primitive form going on inside
his head when he came up with that idea
but it's not shown especially in his
writings from that period it's shown
more in his writings afterward
when he talked when he looked back with
hindsight on his earlier work
and throughout the book there are these
you know brokers these middlemen uh
these kind of supporting characters some
of whom go on to greater fame renown
accolades then even gamov or hoyle and
we can debate that uh one of whom is
willie fowler
and of course the other one is is martin
rile and uh you know these these two
gentlemen went on to win nobel prizes
and get great renown and in some cases
you know superseded what hoyle did at
least in attention but i would say in
terms of their you know kind of
contributions to our understanding of
the universe to popularization of the
universe um uh as we know it uh they
really don't compare to either gammon or
or to uh sir fred hoyle and you know
what's curious to me is
um again
when we paint this picture of hoyle it's
like oh you know he was just this kind
of daughtering guy too in love with his
idea of the steady state and etc and
even after it was uh known to be wrong
he kind of maintained it and and added
epicycles and i've said some things like
that in my past too so i'm not saying
i'm holier than now or sanctimonious in
any way
but um but in reality there really was
no other
way to think about things i think you
know there is this notion and you talk
about mckellar and discovering this um
the state of cyanogen that seemed to
indicate that space was you know three
kelvin and of course gabamov's team
it was in my research it was like every
other year the temperature of the cmb
would fluctuate both because the age was
uncertain by factors of two
and more but also because of you know
some of the
input parameters in their model were
getting refined as nuclear processes
became better understood nevertheless
the temperatures varied from 5 kelvin to
50 kelvin uh and famously of course
dickey had some measurement where he
claimed that he had made it decades
before penzias and wilson but uh i mean
yeah to make of their their predicament
i think we have to be more charitable
right i mean things were very uncertain
unclear it wasn't an era of precision
cosmology when one could say these two
values differ by five sigma and we know
each you know one to the you know sub
percent level so um should we be more
kind of uh you know gracious in our
condemnation of people like hoyle and
it's only in hindsight that we knew the
oh the temperature was three kelvin
right
yeah that's that's true we always look
at uh science stories
in in a simple way we say well this is
how it resolved and this person was
right this person was wrong but it was
was certainly unclear
in in the 1950s and 1960s
uh
especially before um penn zeus and
wilson discovery uh which which side
would win and
the new york times as i showed in my
book uh sometimes it would proclaim
that some measurement uh proved that the
big bang was wrong
uh because uh when experiments were
being done at the kellogg lab uh
caltech
showing that uh hoyle and uh the
burbidges and fowler's model of stellar
nuclear synthesis was correct
and new york times article said well
that means the big bang is wrong of
course both could be correct and which
is what turned out to be the big bang
produces the helium cellular
nucleosynthesis produces everything else
but the simplistic
article said well big bang's a failure
so people were betting on the two
and it was unclear
uh really
until the mid 60s and then afterward the
big bang still had
problems and and even today we're still
trying to resolve things
people like to think of a concordance
model but there's certain parameters
we're still trying to pin down so
the story really really never ends
yeah that's one of the delightful you
know aspects of science i always say you
know science is an infinite game uh that
you can never win science uh like you
can win a chess game but it is composed
of a lot of finite games you know
getting a phd getting a faculty position
getting a nobel prize and one of those
finite game or two of those finite games
uh at least two of them you know hoyle
legitimately lost out on and gamov and
even alpha
until the you know day he died basically
i mean the year after he died the nobel
prize was awarded to a past guest on the
show john mather and hopefully future
guest george smoot uh he could have you
know certainly been been awarded it but
but talk about ryle and fowler because
you know i i point out no one's ever
turned down a nobel prize in physics uh
but they've been a lot to turn down
nobel peace prizes literature prizes
other prizes um so how come these two uh
these two men fowler and ryle um you
know would you speculate of course
they're not around to defend themselves
but um what what do you make of their
kind of willingness to you know claim
credit for stuff that other people did
or not share the credit let me just say
it like that let me say share the credit
with what other people did and and get
in gamop's cases even kind of extends to
the second generation because um his
student vera rubin uh uh who she worked
with him i don't know if she was
actually a student but they worked
together and of course she was
overlooked for her own nobel prize so
talk about this notion of of of how uh
these otherwise great scientists who
collaborated benefited from
collaboration with gamov and how they
were kind of all too happy to to to not
maybe you know kind of share some of the
credit that they did receive
unfortunately with fowler and with camel
well with hoyle and gamma sorry
well in the case of fowler that was kind
of a strange situation because hoyle was
the one who came up with the original
idea of stellar nuclear synthesis and
that was manifest in a 1946 paper
and hoyle
shared the idea with fowler and then
they recruited the burbages and formed a
team of four a quartet
and as you uh
you know nicely point out in your book
um losing the nobel prize uh it's it's
sad that the nobel prize in in physics
in science can never be shared by more
than three people
and can't be awarded posthumously and
and as all these things he pointed out
in terms of of that because uh
the for the quartet should have been
awarded the nobel prize for stellar
nuclear synthesis not fowler so um
there's speculation
and and this is unconfirmed but there's
speculation that hans beta was on the
committee on the selection committee
and um or maybe was the nominator i
should say for that prize and mistakenly
thought that fowler was the head of the
team
since he knew he knew of fowler's work
uh more but there's a lot of speculation
about that nobel prize why hoyo
wasn't awarded it and uh part of it
may have been his advocacy for jocelyn
bell bernal
when uh ryle split the prize with hewitt
and uh for the discovery of pulsars
pulsars and uh jocelyn bell burnell was
excluded which is which is very sad um
because she was the one who first
spotted evidence for pulsars as a
graduate student well i have a
consolation prize for her paul she's
going to be on the into the impossible
podcast on december 10th of this year
which is obviously everybody knows is
alfred nobel's death date and the day
they give out nobel prizes so stay tuned
for that that will be a great
consolation for yeah brian i will look
forward to that
i saw a wonderful program she did
recently on astronomy poetry and that
was really fun wow but she she's amazing
and and really very animated so i'll
look forward to that but um but hoyle
made the mistake of
not just complaining about the noble
committee in that case but also he
complained
uh
about her being left out of of the
of the work of
which which wasn't true she she was
listed she was listed on all the papers
and uh
you know
she she was recognized by the team which
she just wasn't recognized by the
notebook committee
but anyway and then the other reason i
speculate that hoyle didn't i wasn't
sharing the nobel prize was because of
all of his fringe beliefs and
some some of hoyle's
collaborators said well maybe
um
he
uh
he was uh
uh excluded because they didn't want to
award somebody who's talking about
you know life coming from space and all
the these things so there's it's a
complicated situation
but certainly alpha should have won the
nobel prize
and uh i was thinking at the time i was
researching the book
i was inter i interviewed jim peebles
and i was thinking oh he should have
really won the nobel prize and
remarkably a few weeks after i
interviewed him he won the nobel prize
uh yeah that was amazing that was
incredible because
um
i did research from the dicky archives
and realized that peebles
was the one
the main person calculating
the cmb temperature and saying
identifying it with the big bang
identifying with a hot fireball i was as
was said at the time and dickie kept
saying
no it's it's thermalized energy from a
previous incarnation of the universe
dickey would not let go of the
oscillatory universe model he was a
strong advocate of the idea that there
was no singularity
that the big bang
uh was just really
something that was a cycle
and that this cmb was evidence of a
previous cycle
and when people asked him to give talks
about the cmb dickie always said
go to peebles
is better for that and thank you
preferred to talk about his um
his ideas about gravity his idea that of
changeable of the changeable cause uh no
changeable gravitational constant yeah
he was an advocate of what became known
as bronze dickey or jordan bronze dickey
model of the universe he preferred to
look at alternative models of uh
relativity rather than cmb
so it was really people's advocacy
that push for that so
i was delighted i was delighted when he
won the nobel prize
and f i remember correctly you you
played some role in
in uh getting dickies uh you know the
famous gravity groups location uh
historic landmark and physics is that
right paul
yes we uh that's i got to know peebles
because
we my group
uh which is the aps historic site
committee put a plaque
in the building where um where they
worked which used to be called palmer
lab and now is is the uh student center
at princeton yeah we had a plaque
ceremony there and peebles had very
specific ideas for where the plaque
should be
and uh what it should read and so forth
which is really cool yeah working with
him on that he's the most evocular
uh person that i know in this in this
wonderful field that i'm privileged to
work in uh before we wrap up i do want
to talk about kind of modern
incarnations as you know mark twain said
history doesn't repeat but it rhymes and
speaking on the topic of nobel prize
winners this time we'll talk about uh
sir roger penrose
and sir roger's uh 90th birthday was
just last week and we had a fest shrift
as they used to call them for him
remotely uh sponsored by stuart hameroff
upcoming guest on the podcast and uh
this was a wonderful celebration but i
was uh asked to speak about sir rogers
conformal cyclic cosmology
and of course roger and stephen
hawking
made these great contributions to our
understanding of at least classical
general relativity in the context of
singularities and uh and nowadays uh i
well i shouldn't say nowadays for
stephen hawking unfortunately he's no
longer with us but certainly mr roger
has abandoned this notion of a
singularity um my friend and uh
another fellow paul uh paul steinhardt
at princeton einstein professor of
science at princeton has along with his
colleague anna aegis who's an upcoming
guest on the podcast have a cyclic model
neil turock participated on you spoke a
little bit about them but uh what would
what do you think that hoyle and and
even gamov would make of uh of these new
reincarnations you know everything
cyclic is is new again
i have a wood cut that i showed from uh
in my talk to sir roger's birthday
gathering of this egyptian cosmogeny
which really is a cyclic cosmology of
the universe history you know it's 3 000
years old it's older than the uh account
of genesis in some ways so anyway what
do you think that where would this take
hoyle and and and and gamma how would
they react uh do you think i missed we
can't you know this is kind of like uh
uh fan fiction right but uh we're such
big fans of both of them thanks in large
part to your work what do you think
they'd react to these new models of
cycles and and um collapsing universes
and so forth
i think gamov uh would have been open to
the idea of previous incarnations of the
universe he
some occasionally talked about a kind of
big squeeze sort of squeezing
matter from some previous era he didn't
go into specifics into what he called
the lem or the um the matter that made
up the the big bang so um he would have
been open to that and interestingly
enough um
the pre-print of the original
steinhardt paper on cyclic cosmology
appeared before hoyle died so
i always wonder if hoyo read it um i
have no evidence that he read it so he
he wouldn't he didn't wasn't alive when
the actual paper was published but um it
was called the ecryotic universe and uh
i i i always wondered what hoyo would
have thought of that but i think he
would have tried to
mold it into
some form of the quasi-steady-state
universe because he was very very
stubborn about holding on to that in his
later years um
but um i i found the work the early work
of penrose and hawking was instrumental
in convincing
uh dickey's group
dickie to some extent but his group that
there what must have been a singularity
in the universe because
penrose of course showed that black
holes
must
collapse into a singularity and then
hawking time reversed that to show that
the big bang must begin in a singularity
and i show in my book
that dickie kept writing to
uh hawking's advisor dennis yama
well um
you know
is there a way out of this are you sure
you tested every possible
cosmology open cosmology closed
cosmology
because
uh dickie really wanted to believe
that there was a previous incarnation of
the universe that was a there was a way
out of the singularity and xiaomi just
kept saying
uh oh no uh you know hawking keeps
trying all these models and it's always
it always starts in a singularity and
that was
uh sort of a milestone
a theoretical milestone in understanding
the big bang just like the cmb
was a an experimental milestone the
discovery of the cmb
and those both happen in the mid 60s and
greatly revolutionized cosmology
i think uh stephen weinberg recently
departed sadly who said that uh physics
thrives on crises
and uh at the time i think he said an
addendum you know luckily there are no
crises going on right now or that's why
you know physics is stagnating do you
see the current epoch paul is a as a
time of crisis as a time of opportunity
as the chinese allegedly according to
john f kennedy at least uh his purported
claim that the symbol is the same or
comprised of two characters i mean
crisis and opportunity do you think that
uh you know we're kind of in a in a
state where we've become a precision
science we have no things to the to the
fourth decimal place in some cases we
can have uh tension at the five sigma
level these are things that are
unimaginable even when i was a graduate
student in the 90s let alone you know uh
when hoyle and gamma were operating
what do you think they would make of it
would they say this is a time for
opportunity or is it a time for crisis
and stagnation maybe well it depends if
if you like general relativity the way
it stands if you like the standard model
of particle physics the way it stands
and you don't mind the fact that they're
completely different then there's no
crisis but if you are really upset by
the fact that those are completely
different theories describing in one
case three of the known forces in the
other case one of the known forces
gravity
um then it's a supreme crisis because
the two of them can't be reconciled so
it depends on whether or not you're
philosophically okay with saying we have
some forces which operate using a field
theory and and another force
well a quantum field theory i should say
and another force that operates using a
classical fear theory based on space
time as as the field uh then then if you
if you're happy with the separate
theories then there's no crisis
so i'd like to see it a greater unity
but it might turn out that we have to be
satisfied with what we
and the last thing i guess i would want
to speculate on uh or have your
speculation on gamov and and hoyle you
you bring to the forefront the uh the
kind of inception or the nascent
beginning
of computers in the early
uh 60s and and late 50s etc uh that were
made use of by these physicists and part
of the reason you attribute to hoyle's
decline in productivity was you know
being on the top of some mountain in the
lake district they probably didn't have
you know t1 internet ethernet or you
know t10 or whatever gigabit uh quality
service i should say so um
this the rise of of ai of machine
learning
what do you think that that impact you
know would have been i mean imagine a
counter factual history where you know
gamov has a quantum computer and and
hoyle you know would it have made a
difference or were these you know
old-fashioned you know pencil and paper
theorists and and the computer was
mainly to check for people like wagoner
that you mentioned who's a wonderful
person i got the pleasure to know when i
was at stanford
you talk about the impact of computers
and and so forth do you think they would
have made use of these this technology
ai physicist etc machine learning or you
know would they have been just the same
kind of just old-fashioned calculators
that they were on pen and paper well who
got more adept with computers in his
later years and was actually happy in
his final years at cambridge because
they had computers at his institute for
theoretical astronomy that was one thing
he was very happy about um but he didn't
have the computers in the late district
um which was a big problem
gamov
was sort of in the early computer age
where um computers weren't used
for cosmological calculations so much
you know maybe uh you know calculating
things like that military detonations
and things like that um
so uh
he certainly was familiar with computers
but he did he did things more as quick
calculations i think if he had access to
quantum computers he would have told
alfred herman
to learn how to use them and to do the
calculations and to report back to them
yes and they would have been the richer
for it no doubt uh paul i can't resist
if you'll indulge me uh what are you
working on next okay just so curious
well i'm working on a bunch of articles
i have an article
that i'm working on about uh history of
mock's principle and a contribution to
a volume on uh on a history of
experimental testing of general
relativity
in the 1950s and 1960s so i'm
i'm i was asked to contribute
a chapter about john wheeler's
contributions to that
so
i go from books to
short articles and uh i've been
uh fortunate in later years i get a lot
of invitations to write things so
i am happy to work to work on those
things and also
sometimes contribute pieces to my own
blog on medium which is accessible
through my twitter page yeah and i spent
a lot of time on twitter which is either
incredibly beneficial or
uh
otherwise i i haven't decided but it's
it's been a lot of fun getting to know
people on twitter and uh
coming up with new things about einstein
and other people
that
sometimes surprises people
yes i love your twitter feed and lately
i've been asking people you know what
another counterfactual my favorite
lately is you know if twitter existed in
1864 when a young scotsman james clerk
maxwell was coming up with four
eponymous equations that would later
bear his name uh that were ultimately
the first you know kind of quantitative
unification of forces fields and so
forth and physics mathematically
speaking set the pathway for the yang
mills field theory equation uh but
imagine he tweets out you know i've
discovered these equations and well how
does it work well there are these gears
you see there are these gears and
whirlpools and and vortices and space
and the ether and people just mocked
them it would have been ridiculous
and and that's kind of maybe one of the
downsides of of of our modern
communications age and why people like
steinhardt has told me he's never going
to use twitter you know because he has
so many ideas and and sometimes you
don't want to kill them too young right
because they may bear fruit and it's
kind of maybe funny to think about what
gamov would do uh with a twitter account
but but for now i want to thank you paul
so much as usual not only for spending
your valuable time with me but also for
sharing your gifts of writing i always
write an encomium you know hoping that
somebody will read it but i since no
one's going to read it i'll just say
this is what i'll put
on my amazon review when it comes out
i'll say i learned so much from this
topic that i already knew that this is
the surest sign of an expert scholars
touch
so paul i want to thank you for teaching
me you are a teacher of mine and i
appreciate you so much can't wait for
your next work i can't wait for your
next appearance and what i'd really love
is to replicate the drive of gamov and
hoyle with you
we'll rent the cadillac sometime when
you're in la jolla
coast to a cave and and just hang out
fantastic
you could start your own show uh you
know physicists in cars or something
like that
thank you so much as always
great talking to you brian thank you so
much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
do
[Music]